I don't know if you can have a bad day
when you walk out on that stage and
people are just losing their minds of
adoration of what and hanging on every
word you're about to say well it's an
amazing group and the fans bring they
bring such an energy and especially when
you're focused on trying to finish a
movie in in post-production and which
can be a very sort of lonely cavernous
kind of thing to come out to a room like
this with 7,000 people you know excited
and cheering about something that you're
working on it and it's a shot in the arm
we all need yeah it's a you've said this
is the end the last installment is it
bittersweet being out there with
everybody and seeing you know the cast
together it is I mean for me I was not
originally supposed to do this movie so
I didn't think I'd be out on the stage
with them again at all so every every
day on the set every day I'm working on
post every day like this where you go
out to sort of present something is a
very meaningful thing especially knowing
that I won't be doing this with them
again so I'm you know I'm nothing but
grateful to everyone involved we saw the
video of Carrie on stage and we know
that it was shot during episode 7 how
important was it to have her in this
final install we couldn't figure out a
way to tell the end of the Skywalker
saga without Leia and you know saying
that she had passed away or saying that
she was somewhere else or maybe he just
felt all along there was no way and we
realized you know we could never recast
it we didn't wanna do a CG character so
we actually realized there was footage
we could use that we could literally
write scenes around and suddenly have
her as an active part of this movie and
she's great in the film and it still
maybe even more now than ever it's still
impossible to me that she's gone because
she's so she's so alive in the phone
it's so special to the fans though I
know you know that right look we
approached it that way which is we don't
know how to do it without her and so
having her be part of the movie in a way
that I think she'd be proud of is very
meaningful
listen I'm old enough to know that there
was a Felicity reunion on that stage
with you and Gary Russell I love that so
much
do not look old enough to know that I'm
not Carrie is one of my dearest friends
and she obviously could not be a more
the person and she basically did me a
solid by agreeing to be in the movie so
I got to work with Carrie again which
was something that you know I always
loved to do
we love that